They're more than just flickering images on
a screen,
drug public service announcements have been
a part of your life
and a part of your nightmares for decades.
Join us as we count down 5 drug PSAs that
tried to scare the shit out of us but really didn't.
Any questions?
Number 5 is 'This is Your Brain on Eggs'
This is drugs, this is your brain on drugs.
If this late 80s ad brought to you by the
Partnership for a Drug Free America
didn't scare you,
maybe the follow-up containing your scary
alpha male dad did.
This is your brain, this is drugs, this is
your brain on drugs.
The ad was also remade about a decade later.
This is your brain.
Except this time with scary tank tops.
And this is heroin.
It's not over yet.
This is what your family goes through, and
your friends, and your money,
and your self respect and your future.
Any questions?
Number 4 is doctor recommended psychedelic
cartoons.
It's stimulating, it's the in thing, the hula
hoop of the jet generation.
This one is from the American Medical Association
in the 1960s
and to really understand the irony of it's
message
you're gonna want to take a few bong rips
and turn out the lights.
The human brain, after all, is made for thinking,
not fumigating.
It's hardly a tinker toy for experimenting
with drugs.
It's use can lead to abnormal behavior, to
psychological dependence
and to abuse of other drugs.
Number 3, who taught you how to drug?
Answer me, who taught you how to do this stuff?
You alright?
I learned it by watching you.
Parents who use drugs have children who use
drugs.
There isn't much to say about this one.
You already know it's stupid.
People have been making parodies of the ad
for years.
Who taught you how to use this thing?
You alright, I learned from watching you!
I learned it from watching you!
Who gave you these, who taught you about these?
I learned it from you, okay?
I learned it from watching you!
Number 2 is Mr T chokes the drugs out of us.
Little kids doing drugs, it turns my stomach.
Aw that's spilled milk Mr T.
It hurts the user, it hurts his family.
That's got to be like a hundred pounds of
bling there,
it's a wonder his neck doesn't fall off.
It hurts his friends, I just want to shake
some sense into you kids.
Mr T no!
That are using drugs or thinking about using.
Mr T!
So remember don't, or else.
Yeah, sorry T but your aggressive tactics
didn't stop kids from getting hooked on the junk.
But let's hope another message you made did.
Treat her right, treat your mother right.
Treat her right, treat her right.
Mother, there is no other, like mother.
So treat her right.
Number 1 is Peewee cracks us up.
This is crack, rock cocaine.
Yes Peewee Herman of Peewee's playhouse,
the guy whose show felt like a dorm room acid
trip
with it's talking chairs, Genies and dinosaurs.
Which begs the question, is this character
really the best pitch man for the war on drugs?
Everybody wants to be cool, but doing it with
crack isn't just wrong,
it could be dead wrong.
So if Peewee taught us anything about drugs...
I don't know, sorry guys, I took a few puffs
while watching those Peewee's Playhouse clips.
And that's 5, we hope we didn't scare you
too much.
If you aren't high as a kite right now
post some links to more drug PSAs in the comment
section below.